como simbad a playa es hoy una ciudad
fantasma dejada en ruinas y despojada de
sus habitantes durante un año esta
ciudad portuaria fue uno de los
bastiones de los yihadistas de ánsar
al-suna conocidos localmente como al
shabab fue retomada el 8 de agosto por
fuerzas mozambiqueñas y ruandesas que
ahora patrullan la parte norte de la
región de cabo delgado que tenían esta
ciudad por su interés estratégico en
términos de vías marítimas y de
comunicación un lugar que también se
utiliza para planificar otras
operaciones en el interior así que
recuperar esta ciudad era realmente
importante para nosotros la situación de
seguridad aquí sigue siendo muy volátil
los habitantes aún no han podido
regresar a la ciudad
los refugiados que han sido desplazados
en diferentes campos tendrán que volver
y nos estamos organizando para hacer
posible estos factor nos pero existe el
riesgo de que todavía haya insurgentes
entre ellos nuestro trabajo es crear las
condiciones para que la gente esté
preparada para proporcionar
informaciones cuando y si los
insurgentes reaparecen
según el ejército ruandés la mayoría de
los yihadistas han sido replegados más
al sur donde están desplegadas las
fuerzas de la comunidad para el
desarrollo del áfrica meridional ese adc
una fuerza aliada pero separada de esta
acción militar ruandesa kigali lamenta
la muerte de cuatro de sus hombres y
afirma haber matado a un centenar de
yihadistas
y aquí está parte del material enemigo
que capturamos a lo largo del eje norte
desde palma hasta mozimba da praia como
pueden ver hay diferentes tipos de armas
por allí hay ametralladoras por allí hay
cargadores y por allí hay ametralladoras
cohetes y lanzacohetes
prisionero de guerra presentado a los
periodistas dice que fue reclutado a la
fuerza por los shebab
y
nos llevaron al bosque y nos entrenaron
allí nos enseñaron a desmontar una arma
de fuego nos enseñaron a usar
ametralladoras y armas más ligeras
fuimos a palm a preparar emboscadas aquí
esperamos a que llegara los soldados
ruandeses y nos enfrentamos a ellos
los soldados nos llevan ambos otro
bastión yihadista recapturado en agosto
donde se entrenaban muchos insurgentes
se necesitan varias horas del vehículo
para llegar allí en un terreno donde los
riesgos de ataques son altos
cosas
este era el cuartel general táctico del
enemigo del enemigo los insurgentes que
operaban en diferentes zonas de los
alrededores también los expulsamos de
estos lugares se han desplazado más al
sur
al río més haro donde nuestras fuerzas
intentan impedir su presencia
en esta región del norte de mozambique
la amenaza de los yihadistas ha
comprometido las actividades económicas
la empresa francesa total ha iniciado
allí un proyecto de gas valorado en
23.000 millones de dólares se suspendió
el pasado mes de abril después de que
los shebab atacaran la ciudad de palma a
sólo 10 kilómetros de distancia el
ejército ruandés está ahora ha apostado
a los alrededores del lugar antes de la
sublevación ismail trabajaba como
cocinero allí hoy vive en el campo de
desplazados de kit hunda cerca del pozo
de gas y no se atreve a salir
bienvenida a los shebab y mataron a
todos indiscriminadamente descuartizaron
a la gente en mil pedazos y los
esparcieron por la carretera
si uno pasaba por allí podía reconocer a
miembros de su propia familia
no sabemos por qué lo hacen no entiendo
por qué han venido a invadirnos
en el distrito de palma algunos
residentes vieron que la situación se
estabilizaba y decidieron volver a casa
para que bogotá cama y por el cual notar
ese mica memorizó canning
cuando los lleva te atrapan te ordenan
que te quedes quieto matan a los hombres
te obligan a ver la masacre y que
importa si es tu hermano o tu marido
estos asesinos también vestían uniformes
militares y llevaban armas
así que cuando volvemos a ver armas como
esta no nos sentimos seguros pero poco a
poco estamos aprendiendo a confiar en
estos soldados ruandeses allá en el cual
minicolección a dominic oduro y luego
hacer
a pocos metros las atrocidades de los
insurgentes siguen siendo visibles
aquí un trozo de zapato rastro de una
fosa común donde una docena de personas
habrían sido decapitadas hoy los
militares ruandeses patrullan la zona
tres meses después del inicio de las
operaciones el presidente ruandés paul
kagamé visitó cabo delgado con motivo de
un desfile militar organizado por su
homólogo mozambiqueño
entonces
nuestras fuerzas conjuntas han
conseguido hacer retroceder a los
insurgentes y realizar importantes
avances
guisos
africanas
demuestra lo que los africanos podemos
conseguir juntos cuando trabajamos de
forma eficaz
podemos encontrar soluciones a los
problemas más graves
las tropas ruandesas no han dado ninguna
fecha de salida por el momento el país
aprovecha su presencia en el terreno
para desarrollar actividades económicas
durante la visita paul kagamé y filipe
music firmaron un acuerdo de cooperación
en los sectores del comercio y la
inversión